It's often desirable to bring together
data from many sources and providers.
But they may be cautious about
participating because of concerns
about how their data will be used and
whether their institution might
be portrayed negatively or
look bad in some analyses.
One solution, as depicted here for
PopMedNet, is for
each contributing institution to
maintain control of its data in
what is often called a data locker,
but be capable of accepting and
responding to queries that
might go to many data sources.
PopMedNet is intended to support
medical product safety analysis and
comparative effectiveness
research of alternate treatments,
both of which rest on obtaining data
from multiple sources and other studies.